hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster
well Liz truss has been prime minister
for exactly one month today and to say
it's been eventful would be an
understatement in that time she's
u-turned on one of her Flagship policies
introduced a mega budget that sparked a
run on Pension funds and promised to
smash Decades of Treasury Orthodoxy and
even though she's barely had a chance to
unpack a number 10 some of her
colleagues are already talking about how
to replace her as conservative
conference draws to a close in
Birmingham has Liz trust and enough to
steady the ship will bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
in these tough times we need to step up
I'm determined to get Britain moving to
get us through the Tempest and to put us
on a stronger footing as a nation
well protesters disrupted Her speech but
after days of infighting they really
were the least of list trust's worries
is that clear that people are angry
there are always some moaning Minis
always some moaning minis we'll try and
find out if Liz truss can stamp her
authority over the Monas and we'll also
find out what our viewers panel makes of
the prime minister's speech has she won
them over we'll be finding out later on
the program we'll also have some top
guests for you including the former
conservative party leader in Duncan
Smith Labor's Charlotte business
secretary Jonathan Reynolds the former
education secretary and social Mobility
campaigner Justin Greening and to
discuss what all of the week's drama
means for you and your money very
importantly we'll be joined by the
personal finance Expert lawsuiter Plus
much more besides all coming up on the
take
foreign
[Music]
good evening after a turbulent four days
in Birmingham and a dramatic two weeks
for the economy the Prime Minister tried
to reassure us today that she has a plan
listos warned the country will go
through Tempest and disruption but
insisted that everyone will benefit from
her economic policies where we'll
discuss the speech in a bit more detail
shortly but we're going to start with
the best or maybe that should be the
most dramatic bits of the weeks they
fought
we're live at the Conservative Party
Conference here in Birmingham there are
also reports that some conservative MPS
are even prepared to vote against the
budget would they lose the weight yes
they would lose the weight correct
carefully avoiding my question about
whether or not you'll vote for this in
the House of Commons well I don't
believe it's wrong are you absolutely
committed to abolishing the 45 Pence tax
rate for the wealthiest people in the
country yes plans to cut the highest
rate of income tax have been reversed
the conservative parliamentary party
have put handcuffs on Liz trust to stop
her doing things they regard as mad
frankly the 45p wasn't a priority policy
and I listened to people
I have three priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth
let's get them removed later on in my
speech my friends I'm going to talk
about the anti-growth Coalition but I
think I think I think they arrived in
the hall a bit too early
[Applause]
well frankly I'm not sure I've ever been
to a conservative conference quite like
the one we've just had in Birmingham
after the lady who was not for turning
you turned on her pledge to abolish the
45p rate of tax it was open season with
MPS and ministers openly questioning
government policy well as trust
acknowledged in Her speech that these
are stormy days and it might take some
time for the clouds over the
conservative party to dissipate I've
been getting the thoughts of
conservative MP and former party leader
in Duncan Smith who had some strong
words for colleagues that he said should
grow up I started by asking him what he
made with the Prime Minister speech
I thought it was a good speech uh well
delivered uh it was very good as well
because it was short sometimes these
speeches go on forever she set out the
themes but didn't try to delve into the
detail because I think that has to come
later but I think the most eye-catching
part of the speech which made sense
given the
let's be honest pretty awful two or
three days that we had had up there with
various people taking lumps out of each
other I think what was good about her
speech was as she got past that and then
we have uh the juxtaposition which is
perfect which is to say it's the
anti-growth Coalition that we are
against so it's growth versus
anti-growth now I have taught a couple
of Labor colleagues I know and they went
oh I'm not sure about that one
um and I think that's the point so now
you start to frame it so it makes it
more difficult for people to you know
take and take edge with it I suppose you
mentioned a difficult few days a pretty
awful few days with colleagues taking
lumps out of each other
extraordinary hasn't it discipline just
breaking down it has but I was pondering
it I mean I went on yesterday to tell
people just to calm down and just think
about what we're doing here but in fact
as I thought about it yesterday I
thought um
in a way this might be cathartic because
we'd been through a really tough period
this has been a terrible three years no
Governors faced three years like this
with covid and then the postcoded
lockdown Nightmare of You Know higher
inflation a war in Ukraine just about
everything you can think of for three
years has really caused problems with
the government and then we've had the
fall of Boris Johnson and then a
leadership election where the leader
comes who doesn't have a public mandate
because it's not a general election and
people are divided because different
people stood and lots of people
supported Rishi sunak not her so there's
a bit of Edge and bitterness and so I
thought to myself actually on reflection
that this may turn out to be quite
cathartic because the conservative party
I think in this conference stared over
the edge
and I think they step back uh today with
her speech now all I hope is that people
recognize that there is no other way but
to get behind Liz trust and and make it
work for her and I think this growth
versus the anti-growth Coalition is a
very good starting point for
conservative party it could bring them
together very well you see you say that
people will say the age but then realize
there's no other way but to roam behind
Liz truss I have to say that that is
quite different to what some of your
other colleagues are saying at
conference after spending a few days
there there's already talk about
changing the rules of the 1922 committee
so that there could be another
leadership contest or potentially
bypassing the members and MPS deciding
on a Unity candidate because this is
someone who they don't believe can win
an election that's going on
yeah it's going on amongst a few of my
colleagues who you know sometimes need
to grow up and secondly need to figure
out what happens next so if they can't
get Unity now what are they going to
Unity candidate suddenly pop out of
nowhere and say it's all right everybody
we're together they have somebody that
the party voted for it's within the
rules they've got to get behind that
individual that happens to be Liz trust
the second bit about this is if you go
on changing your leaders and having into
Nissan Warfare I tell you what with the
polls the way they are now you might as
well head straight to the exit door
because that's exactly where we will go
and it will be very painful for many
people so it's very true I've seen this
time and time again in the time I've
been in politics is that there are to be
quite Frank with you some people who are
really intellectually challenged about
politics and who don't understand that
it's the electorate that puts us here
and if they lose trust in us and if they
think that we're incompetent because all
we do is fight each other this happened
to labor it's happened to us in the past
and they will not vote for us so what
right now that speech today was really
important because they have to get
behind this concept of us for growth and
those people what she called the
Coalition the anti-growth Coalition we
need to Now understand who the real
enemy is here it's those who are really
opposed to growth and those who actually
want growth and are prepared to take the
decisions are necessary if they can't
fit within that well all I can say to
them is they're on their way out you
have done of work in your time of
politics around poverty I just wonder if
you look at what's happened in the first
month or so of the Liz trust Premiership
trying to abolish the 45p rate of tax
not saying that benefits will be raised
in line with inflation
scrapping the cap on bunkers bonuses
is there a risk that the conservatives
are effectively playing into what some
people have always thought about the
conservatives that you care about rich
people and you don't care about poor
people well I set up the center for
social justice to try and help all
politicians but the conservatives
particularly to understand that it's
important to understand exactly how
difficult it is when you're on low
income because things cost more on low
income than they do for wealthier people
you know you get your bank statement
printed they charge you more for it you
know cash is how you live your life but
you try finding cash sometimes it's
really really difficult so all these
things cost a bit more so my point
really to them was to try and understand
that therefore we have to make sure they
have a flaw put under them so they can
move back into work and you want people
to move back into work there are five
million people outside of that and you
want them to go through so those are the
sort of changes you need and the reality
really for all of us is not to make
simplistic Solutions the answer to this
we want people to move back into work I
did the big reforms on Universal Credit
help people survive through the pandemic
it's there to be used it's very good
about getting people back to work and we
need to make sure that we understand
that nature and the one if I have a
criticism at all uh this phrase uh the
growth uh those in favor of growth
versus the anti-growth coalition
that actually should have started two or
three weeks ago because the argument
right now that we should be making is
those who are in favor of growth what
growth does for those on the lowest
incomes lifts their incomes gives them
more jobs gives them more opportunity
it's not about wealthier people
particularly it's about people on low
incomes of growth we should have made
that argument all the way through then
talked about tax and be very careful
about then how you juxtapose that so the
45p tax rate was uh when set against
benefit Cuts is just stupid and
therefore that both needs to be cleared
out the way Liz has done one and I think
they'll clear the other out of the way
too and just to be clear by clearing the
other out the way you're saying that
benefits should effectively rise in line
with inflation Yes again I have to keep
getting my colleagues and others this is
looking backwards okay so the last rise
was below inflation at the time it Rose
because it was based on the previous six
months where inflation wasn't as high so
actually already benefits would come in
under inflation at the next one in a way
it'll be setting resetting the bar so
that they're stable my view on this is
it's it's the key to get into getting
the benefit bill down is to get people
back to work that was always what we
designed in Universal and you think then
they go paying tax and then we become do
you think that list Russia should come
out now and commit to saying that
benefits will go up in language well I
think as was probably I think the
government's going to have to say
something about this clearly I don't I
understand fully why she couldn't say
anything during the conference I have no
problem about that and therefore those
who are fighting to say say something or
not say something I think the truth is
she's not going to jump ahead of the
statement they're going to make on the
economy because it would be Daft you
then start ruling out all sorts of stuff
and you never get anywhere but when
that's done I think they need to make it
clear that actually that's not the right
way to go because you want people to be
able to move swiftly up into work and if
you reduce that amount of benefit
they're getting which by the way isn't
that great then it makes it more
difficult to take the big jobs the big
choice about taking those jobs doing
part-time work moving up the scale so
and then of course the living crisis
with inflation everything else bearing
down on them and as I said earlier on at
the lowest level of income the cost of
living is actually higher because things
are more expensive so we need to take
that into consideration as well it's not
the same yes there are lots of things to
be done in taxation I think particularly
the thresholds by the way which drags
senior teachers senior nurses in who are
not wealthy people that needs to be
looked at when we get to that but that's
my personal view but when they talk
about people on benefits we should
recognize a lot of them are beyond the
world of work and so you've got to be
very careful how you do this and I think
for a party like mine if you're talking
about growth talking about tax cutting
you can make sure the message is
well-rounded and you understand the
problems that exist for those down at
the lower incomes
in Duncan Smith uh well let's get the
thoughts about Deputy political editor
Sam Kate she's made it back from the
Conservative Party Conference in
Birmingham today to talk to us how are
you still holding up okay lots of coffee
uh excellent that's what we like to hear
um what did you make of Ian Duncan Smith
I thought he was actually quite
outspoken when he was talking about you
know his colleagues need to grow up but
also on benefits Cuts as well as saying
that it would be it was stupid to talk
about uh a tax cut for the richest
people and at the same time potentially
a benefits cut for those on Lower
incomes so at the moment the
conservative party is spending a lot of
time having to hold
let's be honest basically contradictory
ideas in the head so on the one hand in
the interview with you just now in
Duncan with telling Tory MPS to fall in
line on the other he was setting out
what could actually effectively be a
challenge to Liz truss who we think does
still want to increase benefits not in
line with inflation but in line uh with
earnings which is substantially less
meaning those Universal Credit getting
maybe half as much of an increase as
they otherwise would have done uh when
it's upgraded next year so is he being
loyal or is it being difficult well
that's the problem that's just a little
flavor of one of the problems facing Liz
truss at this conference this is her
earlier today standing behind the podium
in the Birmingham Conference Center
it was a speech that gave us a headline
Vision I mean you were bludgeoned with
the key phrase growth growth growth but
the question is kind of where we go from
there because even there when you look
at the vision there are some
contradictions she talks about wanting
higher growth lower taxes a smaller
state
she clearly wants to slash public
spending but she also wants a better NHS
and is also promising reassurance for
people at this point with the cost of
living crisis and it it's not quite
clear to me how we do all of those
things all at once
um so I'm interested to get your take
after spending what four five days in
Birmingham and talking to lots of MPS
talking to lots of members or all the
people there in the party in Birmingham
how secure is listro's position
well
I suppose the problem
is that there is no plot to ask Liz
trust there is some concern about her
future after the last few days but we
learned a lot in Birmingham this week
the most important Moment In This Party
Conference came on social media at 7 20
am on Monday morning and that was the
moment that Liz truss and her Chancellor
quasi-classing basically abandoned the
fight over giving the very richest in
this country a big tax cut that's
getting rid of the additional rate of
tax at 45p for those I think over 150
000 pounds and the reason that's so
significant is that was a moment where
basically Liz trust who likes to pretend
he'd like to present herself as a lady
not for turning Ella Thatcher was forced
by her MPS to abandon a flagship policy
is an enormous Revolt led by Michael
Gove he's the internal leader of the
opposition is quite clear Grant chaps
the man with a spreadsheet the man with
the numbers uh Michael Grove touring
fringes nine fridge meters uh in a day
and effectively she was forced to do it
by them now
what everybody recognized instantly was
that they had made her act on one
unpopular policy but it's not the only
one there are lots and lots of bits of
Liz truss's addendum particular growth
which requires getting rid of planning
regulation getting rid of environmental
regulations getting rid of all sorts of
things that actually previous prime
minister wanted to do but haven't been
able to get through Parliament so the
question isn't yet whether or not Liz
trust is whether Liz trust is safe the
question is whether or not Liz truss
actually can deliver the kinds of things
that she wants because
ultimately she is being forced by her
MPS to back down on key things and could
be forced again is it effectively the
case that we're going to end up with Liz
truss but with our mandate from her MPS
to govern if so do we have something
approaching a kind of zombie government
in order to uh over the next few months
interesting stuff and I think that was
what uh actually led to perhaps one of
the most memorable lines of conference
from you saying that MPS had I think
handcuff Liz trust to stop her doing
things that they regard as mad uh Sam
thank you very much indeed for your
analysis as always
well there was a new catchphrase in the
prime minister's speech today to
describe the opposition parties and
groups who in her view don't like the
government's growth agenda
labor the lib Dems the SMP
the militant unions the vested interests
dressed up as think tanks the Talking
Heads the brexit deniers extinction
rebellion and some of the people we had
in the hall earlier it's always more
taxes more regulation and more meddling
wrong wrong
[Applause]
well I spoke earlier to the Charlie
business secretary Jonathan Reynolds and
asked for his reaction to this trust
describing labor as part of the
anti-growth coalition
when Liz truss has created an economic
crisis in Downing Street we're all gonna
have to pay for that to hire mortgages
higher bills for pretty much everything
and then she has the cheek not even to
acknowledge that but to accuse the rest
of the country of being part of this
anti-growth Coalition I mean quite
simply growth under the last Labor
government was considerably higher than
it has been under the last 12 years of
conservative government and I'd be very
confident in saying our plans for the
future are more realistic for stronger
growth than tax cuts for the already
built well-off if you're Keen to try and
get higher growth as labor says it is do
you need to look at two policies that
the conservatives are famously a little
bit nervous about higher integration and
looser planning regulation well the core
for us is the fact that this country has
the lowest rate of business investment
in the G7 so how do you drive that up
well you've got to get past the kind of
chaos economic instability you've had
under the last 12 years of conservative
government so I would say the main thing
is that a long-term policy framework a
modern industrial strategy institutions
that people have confidence in so they
know it's not going to change when
businesses I was asking about two
specific policies immigration planning
reform and I'm not clear what it is
specifically you're talking about in
your answer rather than you know
long-term strategies and what's about
business investment is the core of this
country's poor economic performance for
the last 12 years those two things that
they play some role but unless you're
attracting long-term investment to the
UK businesses having the confidence to
invest you're not going to see a change
to that and nothing I see in the
conservative
proposals for put forward so far address
the fact that they themselves to be
frank have been a cause of a lot of the
instability that has prevented that a
lot of businesses such as you know the
head of the CBI the biggest business
organization at Terry danker telling me
on Sunday the biggest thing is migration
people want to see and more immigrants
coming to the UK to try and help fill
some of those all-important jobs would
labor like to see higher immigration
well look I accept the point if you talk
to most businesses they will identify
labor and skill shortages as a major
barrier to growth we've got to accept
immigration is high at the minute it's
different to how it was under freedom of
movement when we're members of the EU
but it is high so we would like to see a
closer relationship between immigration
numbers the shortage occupation list and
the skills investment that goes on in
the UK so if you're putting an
occupation on the shortage occupations
list you're also triggering a response
from government in terms of the
investment in skills investment in this
country so people can have confidence
there's a long-term plan that isn't just
based on immigration I recognize it's a
big issue for businesses but they've got
to accept that the public have concerns
about that too so do you say that
immigration is hard you think it's too
high immigration has to reflect the
needs of the economy and the fact that
let's be frank we're an aging population
and we've got to bring people into this
country I don't think getting back to
where you know the conservative
governments of the past have been about
putting arbitrary Targets on it is in
any way helpful for the simple fact they
never got anywhere near those targets so
what's the point in having them I don't
think that's a helpful way to do it
you're going to acknowledge public
concerns as well as acknowledge business
concerns that this is a significant
problem for them okay
now just you know we're back in London
now we're here in Westminster I've been
to both labor and the conservative
conference I have to say there was a
pretty clear difference in atmosphere of
both
how does it feel
for as a labor politician to be looking
at the conferences and the inviting is
not at labor for once but at the
conservatives well look I'm also pleased
to see labor doing well I want us to be
leading in the opinion polls but look
we've had to earn that we've had to
recognize the defeat in 2019 have a
leader in Kia storm who's moved the
party on and listen frankly to where
people weren't willing to support labor
in the past so look we we're doing what
we can I'm going to continue doing what
we can to continue to build and earn
that trust it is true I mean you look at
conservative conference it looks chaotic
it looks like there's no kind of
internal discipline or consistent
approach to any issue but look that is
that is set from the top it comes from
this trust it comes from quasi quatang
and I think to be honest until they are
willing to acknowledge the scale of the
economic crisis they created with that
mini budget and what it means for every
household every family it is the whole
economic crisis so did they come on I
mean look at inflation rates globally
look at the war in Ukraine look at you
know what's happening those are factors
look at government borrowing I mean what
they created with that mini Budget on
Friday Friday was an increase in
government borrowing costs so
historically unprecedented it took a
substantial intervention from the bank
of England to save the defined benefit
pension industry in the UK these are not
small things I mean look at where if you
want to get a new mortgage if you
remortgaging or buying a property right
now look at the best fixed term rate you
will get it's around six percent it's a
real significant changes that come not
just from Individual policy decisions
that were made but from people looking
at this government and saying this is a
government that we can't trust we can't
trust them to have faith and respect for
the institutions that we base our
economic policy making on in this
country and once you've lost that
confidence it's very very hard to get
back and neither litros or
quasi-quartile in my view will ever get
that confidence back um you say that
neither Liz trust or quasi quantity in
your view will get the economic
confidence back
consult to MPS famously ruthless in
getting rid of leaders do you think
you'll be facing Liz truss at the next
election well look it's clearly been a
disastrous start but she's responsible
for that she will have to own that I
would genuinely say no you expect me to
want a general election because I'm in
opposition and I'd like to replace the
government political instability does
have a corresponding effect on economic
instability and if the conservative
party thinks it can change its leader
again so soon without a corresponding
impact of that on people's lives on
their incomes again on their mortgages
well they've got to acknowledge they
would have that so the genuine soundest
safest thing for this country would be a
general election and a chance to replace
the conservative party in government
entirely you're on an election fitting
now then yes and we've got to be but
look we've had elections at short notice
in the past so I think everyone from
2019 onwards has always had that but
we're going to continue doing what we've
done since that defeat which is
acknowledged where we went wrong win
back people's trust have clearly costed
policies have a commitment to a kind of
fiscal responsibility which is
completely lacking from this government
and I feel very very confident very
happy with the labor party on his
current direction under Kia Stormer and
we'll continue to do the work we've got
to do
Jonathan Reynolds talking a little early
to be there we've been talking an awful
lot about the political landscape on the
show today but obviously the most
important thing is the impact that
policy has on people's lives and today
the interest rate on two-year fixed
mortgages passed six percent that's the
highest it's been since 2008 when we're
joined by Laura Suter who is head of
personal finance at AJ Bell thank you
very much for coming in to talk to us
today there's going to be lots of people
frankly really worried about what is
happening with interest rates what's
happened to their mortgages and how
difficult is the situation it's really
tricky for anyone who's either on a
variable rate mortgage which means their
mortgage goes kind of up and down with
the base rate or anyone who's coming to
remortgage those people are going to
face really big shocks because they
might have got their previous mortgage
on a very cheap deal a couple of years
ago where mortgage rates were very cheap
but we've obviously now seen them shoot
up on top of that lots of lenders have
pulled their mortgage deals in recent
weeks which means that actually getting
a hold of a mortgage there's just far
fewer to pick from Far few lenders out
there just what does that mean then
knock on effect does that mean you might
actually just get rejected for mortgages
or does it mean that you're just going
to have to pay more if you get one it
means there's less Choice out there it
means people that are in trickier
circumstances so maybe those people with
poorer credit ratings or don't have a
kind of straight forward example
straightforward application they might
struggle to find a smaller lender who
would have previously been willing to
deal with them but also they'll be
facing higher rates less choice just
means generally higher rates the
chancellor quasi quateng is going to be
meeting with mortgage lenders tomorrow
we understand is there much the
government can actually do here
so the way I won't get into too much of
the technical detail for fear of sending
you to sleep but the way that mortgages
are priced is based on something called
swap rates and effectively that's based
on the estimations of what interest
rates are going to be obviously the
reaction that we sought in the mini
budget was a massive increase in the
expectations of what interest rates were
going to rise to they we then thought
that they were going to hit about six
percent in May last year since then it's
calmed down slightly but only slightly
we're now expecting them to hit around
five and a half percent in May next year
that's much higher than we were
expecting pre-mini budget and all of
that means that mortgages are just more
expensive for the mortgage companies to
the to borrow money and so they have to
increase their rates so I think my
shorter answer to that would be no no do
you think there's anything that happened
over the last four days at Conservative
Party Conference that has really moved
the dial when it comes to mortgages and
personal finance so what we have seen is
is markets have come down a bit
obviously the pound has rebounded event
markets are back up a bit and those
interest rate expectations have dropped
slightly they're still way above where
they were but they have dropped slightly
and I think some of that Panic that we
saw immediately afterwards where
mortgage lenders had to pull their
mortgages because they just weren't sure
how to price them we're starting to see
that go away we've seen lots of the big
lenders come back to Market and we'd
hope to see more of that in coming days
so some of that kind of I guess Panic
has died down definitely one thing that
you know you sometimes hear
um from people of an older Generations
look interest rates has been high before
um actually it's it's all fine why are
people overreacting it is anything
changed from the last time that interest
rates were this High I think we're in a
very different environment I definitely
hear that argument a lot what we also
have at the moment is soaring house
prices and the house price as a multiple
of your earnings which is quite a good
measure are much higher than they were
back then I'm also I'd never fully
bought into that argument because I
don't think anyone was enjoying paying
15 16 on their mortgages back then and
relish that time so I'm not sure why we
want to return to it at that time lots
of people's homes were repossessed lots
of people couldn't afford their mortgage
payment and are you worried that that
might happen again now particularly as
you say that people tend to have bigger
mortgages just to afford the houses
exactly and particularly I think if we
think about people first-time buyers
that have bought in recent years they've
borrowed the maximum they could they've
bought with very small deposits just to
get on the housing ladder
um and they bought they got their
mortgage at a cheap rate previously if
they're coming off those deals where
maybe they were paying one percent
previously we're now seeing those
interest rates at six percent on quite
chunky mortgages I think it's that group
of people that we might see struggle to
afford those higher payments any good
news for us
I always like to have some good news so
Rising interest rates does mean that
it's better news for Savers so anyone
out there who does have some spare money
spare cash set aside
um should be getting a much higher
interest rate on those savings they will
need to switch the bank won't just hand
them that money so they do need to
switch account to get those higher rates
so anyone who has got savings out there
that they haven't had to dip into yet
because of the cost of living crisis you
can get a much better return on that if
you shop around for a better deal good
advice there a little bit of uh you know
switching around looking at the market
is a good thing to do right now thank
you so much for coming in and talking
through some of the implications of what
people are seeing in their everyday
lives really important to hear
and now tomorrow at midday I can tell
you that Jane's second will be here with
a cost of living special we're going to
be talking to our economics editor Ed
Conway the business presenter Ian King
City editor Mark clymen and also our
Deputy political editor Sam coats about
the dramatic economic and political
events over the last week so do check
that one out
you're watching the take we're live in
Westminster up next we'll be talking to
our viewers panel and find out what
people are home made of the prime
minister's speech
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we are live in Westminster
for you and we've had lots of takes this
evening so let's get a take from our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates again
at shall we
um
we'll be talking a lot about politicians
we're talking a lot about MPS reaction
right and how the prime minister is
controlling her own party how's it going
down with voters you're right Sophie
what's really interesting about the
challenge facing this trust is that
there are really three audiences at the
moment you mentioned MPS that's one of
them another one is the market because
there's a lot of worry about whether or
not Britain can afford to borrow on the
scale that Liz trust wants to borrow so
that's a second key audience that she's
got to do and then alongside that she's
got to do voters and juggling all three
is proving quite difficult now one of
the fascinating things about Liz truss
and her Premiership which is she was
elected to chosen by the conservative
party one month ago I mean I cannot
believe absolutely Eon to go I can't
believe it's any money is that almost
every new prime minister has had a
bounce but let's look at this because
I'm not sure it's true this time here is
the popularity of the vet of the labor
and the conservative leaders so if you
look at Boris Johnson right back when he
was just was elected and he spiked in
the middle of the covid pandemic and
then there was a gradual decline and
this is when party happened uh he left
office uh when uh he had population
level of minus 50 that's a number of
people who says that he they like him
minus the number of people that say that
they don't and look at Liz truss so she
has in the first month of her
Premiership basically plunged to a worse
figure worst popularity figure that at
any point during Boris Johnson's uh
Premiership and he was ejected by his
MPS because of a series of personal uh
uh scandals and also objective because
they thought his poll ratings are poor
and look at what's happened here yes and
of course this is the end of uh
conference season thank goodness we've
had two weeks uh now this week's
obviously been dominated uh by the
Tories but last week we were in
Liverpool for the labor party and it's
really interesting looking at kirst
Armor's uh poll ratings now he never
quite was as popular that was the moment
that he was chosen by the labor
membership to be leader and as we go
forward through 2012 you never quite got
back to that high but after this
conference season he is you can see just
beginning not quite in positive
territory there but um just in the last
few weeks there has been an uptick in uh
uh a positive view amongst the public
and there is more importantly quite a
gap with people much preferring kirst
armor to Liz trust because in the end
any general election will be seen as a
contest between those two leaders
embodying all the parties uh all the
values of the passes that they represent
how hard do you think it could be for
Liz trust to recover from here because
if you look at that line and it's
basically vertical isn't it I mean look
she's had a rocky start she would say
that things were always going to be
bumpy at the beginning because of the
course of living crisis because of the
war in Ukraine is it recoverable
so this doesn't tell you who's going to
win the general election it's pretty
important to say that indeed you ask
other questions about whether parties
are popular which is a bit more like
what you get on the on the on the ballot
um and if you look down into that data
what you discover is a quite a lot of
people now have detached from the
conservative party but a lot of those
people haven't even now managed to go
all the way across and said that they're
going to vote labor now labor had a 33
Point uh lead over the conservative
parties in a poll last week but you're
still seeing problems in Scotland
labor are catching up amongst older
people but aren't overtaking and lots
and lots of people are still in the
don't know column so it's looking good
for labor but there is such an electoral
Mountain for them to climb but the
problem is they're Sophie
um I felt that what we were getting in
Birmingham this week was the first sign
that conservative party and the country
were coming to um coming to terms with
what's going to be a second massive cost
of living crisis and that's the one
caused by higher interest rates has to
do with mortgages and you've got 1.8
million people over the next year who've
got to renegotiate their deal uh all of
them finding that they're going to pay
hundreds of pounds a month more in the
face of that plus everything else it is
really hard let's talk about our next uh
poll shall we this is quite interesting
because the question is should there be
a general election in the next few
months and I'm interested in this
because politicians always tell me the
last thing the public wants is a general
election is that true lasting journalist
once at the moment is a general election
as well you definitely need to sleep
after the last few days look what just
just uh just at the moment two MPS are
panicking they've got three options they
can do nothing they can get rid of their
leader and place them with another
leader because they're worried that Liz
trust isn't doing well or they could
bring down the house and trigger a
general election so do the public the
public up for that well if you look at
this four out of ten members of the
public say that there should be a
general election set against a little
over 20 who say uh that they shouldn't
so actually there's quite a big minority
there now needless to say supporters of
the labor party overwhelmingly think
they should and supporters of the
liberal Democrats think that they should
but look at this over four out of ten
conservative voters think that there
should be a general election now now
they can't be looking at the political
situation thinking it's going well is
this a reflection of nervousness about
Liz trust is it a desire simply for the
policy to go into opposition for a
period of time to sort out its problems
that were on display in Birmingham this
week and then coming back maybe after
labors had to deal with the most
difficult part of the cost of living
crisis on a firmer footing it's not
going to be easy just a quick thought
from you
how big amount a problem is Liz truss's
perceived lack of mandate you know she
hasn't won a general election right
Lee's trust has ripped up so many things
that Boris Johnson uh was doing and
changed direction of this government and
found that
um uh there's no and has no mandate for
that from the public it hasn't been in a
general in in a um in any kind of
Manifesto elected by the public
but there's a bigger there's a little
bit of a sort of techy theoretical
argument people could get quite close
about it but it's quite common in
British politics happened 2007 it
happened in uh in 2016. but here's the
thing this is uh she has to rely on her
MPS to get anything done at all they
have to we have a parliamentary system
and the Prime Minister relies on the
Goodwill of her uh of her party to pass
this bold agenda she thinks that she was
chosen by the conservative party to
deliver and what we learn in Birmingham
this week is that they're not keen we're
effectively getting a Liz trust
Premiership possibly to living in
something a bit more like a Russian
Scenic agenda well that really would be
interesting to see Sam thank you very
much indeed Liz trust Premiership
delivering a Rishi Scenic agenda well
after all the political drama that we've
been talking about we're talking about
the polls there as well but what are
people watching on Sky News make of it
all I'm very pleased to say we are now
joined by our viewers uh panel uh great
to see you all uh today uh now I'm
really interested to uh first of all uh
get the answer to a question that my
producer Jared uh posed to you before
the show and that was
if you could choose the next prime
minister
who would you go for and I'm hoping
you've got pieces of paper written with
a name written down if you do then just
hold them up because I'm very interested
to know
who you have gone for let's have a quick
look so we've got kirstama we've got Liz
truss we've got Boris but give Liz a
chance another Kirsten another list
truss and this is great Martin Lewis uh
the uh I can see with the cost of living
crisis why Martin Lewis could be a
popular uh choice right let's go first
of all to uh Belinda Belinda just
explained to me why you think uh who you
think should be the next prime minister
and why
uh Liz trust she said trust me so trust
trust and
um I thought she was so confident
there's got to be something behind it I
hope to not be so naive and uh you know
she went to a comprehensive school so
people can relate to her she mentioned
you know she wanted especially with
women she wanted people to not go
through or feel the same thing as she
did so she's got some girl power
ammunition ready and
um you know just build Britain which
Boris was talking about so there's got
to be something behind it surely you
couldn't be that confident and not have
maybe they know something we don't in
trust We Trust they go or a bit of a
tongue twister let's bring in vic
Daniels now shall we I think I'm
interested in your thoughts because she
said you'd quite like Boris Johnson back
but you still would like to see Liz
truss given a bit more of a chance what
did you think of her conference speech
I think it was okay I mean you know it
wasn't fantastic but in the
circumstances it was uh it was you know
it was about as good as we could we
could have expected
um I think we've got to stick in this I
think at the end of the day
um it'll be turkey's voting for
Christmas if the MPS Turf her out
um because I think label would clearly
get in if there was another election uh
two years is a long time as well I mean
go back to 2017 when Theresa May was
prime minister I think a lot of
conservatives at that stage at some time
during that year were thinking that you
know the the the Tories will just be
completely devastated at the next
election and two years later things have
changed Boris came in and at the end of
the day biggest majority for the
tourists since 1988. so two years is a
long time let's give Liz a chance okay
let's give Liz a chance so quite
positive from our first two panelists
let's bring in Thomas shall we Thomas
Horn Thomas is 19 so you can actually
vote in the last uh general election who
would you be going for this time
I'd have to go for Kia stama given what
I've seen over the last few days I just
don't understand it like that list
clearly does not know
the consequences of what she's doing you
look at the things she's saying and the
effects they're having and they don't
marry up and it's quite obvious that you
know she's got open disputes within our
cabinet about
of a policies like benefits and whether
they're going to rise with inflation and
I just think she's lost control before
she's even started really
um well let's bring in Hannah shall we
because Hannah I loved your Martin Lewis
suggestion I have to say uh Hannah
Walker you voted labor last time um who
why why would you like to see Martin
Lewis as prime minister
well I think it it's quite difficult to
project Charisma if you don't actually
have an ill I don't think let's trust
has got me and I think saying the words
doesn't give you Charisma
um and I think she's lost control of the
economy for ideological reasons and
that's not a good thing um it isn't
growth she needs to be focusing on
because there's there's no time for that
people need money no we can't wait for
the for that medium term economy to grow
um millions of British British the
British people need help right now or
they they will completely lose their
lives their jobs
um and I don't think she any longer has
the right to speak as she does on behalf
of the British people
now as you say you know it's definitely
a really difficult time for lots of
people and we can bring in at least in
our Lisa Goddard who's talking to us
from Birmingham so where the conference
was and Lisa
you know just just hearing about you
know your own sort of story you know you
like loads of people have seen the cost
of living go up your mortgage has gone
up 250 pounds a month your gas bill has
gone up from 80 pounds a month to 200
pounds a month I mean these are pretty
big risers um do you think Liz truss is
doing enough to help
no I appreciate what she's done for the
gas and electric bills but uh we're
missing the point and and she blames
Putin I understand that but the
conservative government ignored the
Russian problem for many years uh
my when I calculated it Jacob Bruce
marks said people are going to be better
off so I actually added it up and I will
be 4 356 pounds a year worse off at the
end of this month because of the jump in
my mortgage and that's and my gas and
electric and that doesn't even bring in
food Fuel and and I am lucky to be in
not a bad paid job we're going to
struggle so what does that mean for
people who aren't in such a good
position uh and as a working in
education we've not had a realistic pay
rise on inflation for over 10 years and
we've just continued and continued and
it's just not good enough it's just not
good enough we need panty Rises I'm
gonna have to stop you there but I think
what you're saying really resonates with
an awful lot of people let's bring in
Rob shall we conservative voter what did
you make of Liz Truss
um I think that's um as Vic said already
I think that we need to give us a chance
uh she's been in a month she's been
um
overseeing a time uh unprecedented
difficulty with the war in the Ukraine
with the loss of our our late Queen
um it's almost it's almost The Perfect
Storm for this you can't expect
everything to be fixed in a week or a
month or even a year we need to give her
a chance now and we need for the
opposition to back off we need the media
to back up and give her a chance to move
forward there you are give Liz truss a
trans lovely to speak to all of you
shaking your head there I can see but
lots of split opinions on our panel very
Lively discussion much appreciated lots
more coming up on the take this evening
next up we'll be talking to Justin
Greening
foreign
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Skye's Midlands
correspondent and this is where I grew
up we can reveal that the driver who hit
Harry Dunn is 42 year old Anne sekulas
just met the president and we never
thought we'd get this far this this is
what they're up against that the wind is
the really big problems it is back
breaking work and the smoke is thick
working well water levels are dropping
but no one knows what impact further
rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really
terrified in this community I'm told
that everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
I never knew they would make it it's
amazing change seems tantalizingly close
in this corner of the UK Wales was the
first to introduce the plastic bag
charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back well let's crack
straight on shall we here's Justin
Greening with her perspective on Liz
truss's speech
it was a
Bove decent conference speech I think
she was very clear about what she's
trying to achieve as a prime minister I
think it mirrored a lot of messages that
she had put out there during the
conservative leadership campaign I think
maybe the challenge also though is that
in a sense it hasn't addressed any of
those fundamental gaps that we saw open
up during this Conservative Party
Conference this sense that almost we got
to the end of a leadership contest and
yet it feels I think for the public like
somehow it's still going on in the in
the conservative party right now
I have to say uh I've been to quite a
lot of conservative party conferences in
my time quite old now but I haven't
really been to one quite like this uh
Liz trust abandoning her Flagship one of
her Flagship policies the 45p uh
abolition of that rate of tax 24 hours
after defending it and then since then
it's been a free-for-all with different
cabinet ministers coming out commenting
on different policies has the prime
minister's Authority completely gone
I think it's really difficult Sophie
you're right from my perspective you
could see this U-turn coming down the
track really the week before obviously
to have it at conference was probably
the most damaging time you could have it
um as an incoming prime minister and I
think the concern from my perspective
was when you listen to people like
Michael Gove talking about his
opposition to it it was very values
based actually it wasn't just about a
narrow policy question on 45 Pence
um the income tax rate and sure enough
the next day we then moved on to a
debate about whether benefits should be
uprighted in line with inflation so
my concern for the party is that there
are these different camps that
fundamentally have different views and
different values perhaps about where
they want the party to go and that
doesn't just get resolved by one or two
policy policy shifts and I think that's
the debate that we'll go back into
Parliament when everybody arrives back
in the House of Commons on Monday next
week
I'm interested to know your own position
on this you know when you're in
Parliament you're always someone who
championed social Mobility uh for
example
um what side of the debate are you on
so you're right I mean for me any of
these policy questions I would look at
through the lens and does this help
Drive Social Mobility does it help Drive
leveling up there's no doubt that when
you look at the benefit situation
actually people slipping into debt
is often very hard for them to get out
of and therefore making sure we mitigate
that risk that people are really worried
about over the coming months I think is
very important so that the benefits
question I think it is important from my
perspective that that stays in line with
inflation but of course this is a debate
for the the Parliamentary party this was
very clear that she didn't believe in
more handouts and so I don't think the
position she's taken so if he's a
particular surprise I think on the
broader package obviously doing the cost
of living package made sense I would
have liked to see I said this on your
program in the summer her and Rishi
sunak come together on that earlier in
the summer have got that out of the way
and that probably would have brought her
much more time as an incoming prime
minister to work out a full growth plan
that included how she was going to pay
for the measures as well as setting out
the measures in more detail and I think
it's been mixing up and modeling in a
sense those things things together
that's been extremely difficult for I
think the key thing frankly from my
perspective that I still want to see
from this incoming government is a much
more ambitious plan on skills I'd
actually like to see in emergency skills
budget
that addresses key issues that are
holding back growth like the fact that
the apprenticeship Levy itself for
businesses is stopping them from
investing billions of pounds in
developing skills there's some really
practical issues there Sophie I hope
that once people are back in Parliament
that they can then get on and set out
what they're going to do as a new
government to deal with them it's been
an incredibly difficult beginning for
Liz truss as a prime minister I think
that is absolutely cleared she's had a
u-turn on some of her policies already
she's her under her Authority has been
undermined by some people around her in
cabinet we've seen poll leads for labor
that we haven't seen since the early
days of Tony Blair do you think there's
any chance that the conservatives could
win the next election with bliss trust
as prime minister
I think you could you can always have
some chance of pulling things around
turning them around if you'd said to
um labor activists after the 2019
election when they had this huge
Landslide defeat by Boris Johnson what
that they'd be 33 points leader they
changed leader though
true but again you look at kirstama he
was won by election away Batley and
spend from probably being replaced so
all we know Sophie is that politics is
extremely febrile but the bottom line is
whatever the politics this is a time of
Crisis for Britain economically there's
the war in Ukraine what people actually
want to see is the conservative party
now coming together it's had its
leadership contest it cannot keep on
going so those differences need to be
resolved one way or another in
Parliament that's not just something I
want to see that's a lot of the
activists I spoke to at Conservative
Party Conference want to see that too
because the most important thing is
actually less the party and more the
fact that it's a party in government and
it needs to deliver on addressing many
of those crisis issues that people are
really worried about day in day out at
the moment in The Wider country
that's it for another extraordinary week
see you next Sunday